if you're an 18 year old American and
you're thinking about going to college
become a doctor or a vet or architect
probably not a bad idea but if you don't
know what you want to study you might
not want to go to college in the first
place but how do you think about what
you should do
well a man called Ken Rusk who's a
business owner an advocate for Blue
Collar Jobs made a lot of money in Blue
Collar jobs has thought a lot about how
to make those decisions we sat down with
him for a new episode of Tucker Carlson
today and he told us here's how young
people should think about their lives
interesting
foreign
nobody ever looks at somebody and says
I'm totally interested in what your
future looks like to you okay I want to
see you break your future down into a
million little pieces and then get those
pieces one little step at a time and
here's how we're going to do it so I
want you to draw what your favorite
house might look like
and then I want you to draw your
favorite mode of transportation car bike
truck whatever
then I want you to draw your favorite
give back moment your charity moment if
you had an extra 100 bucks what would
you do with it time talent and treasure
what would you give away right
now I want you to draw your favorite pet
dog cat what color what would you name
it let's talk about your favorite
vacation
I want you to draw your health moment
and your spiritual moment let's draw
this out on a poster board and keep it
in front of you because Tucker only one
percent of the population is willing to
go that far
so why shouldn't I be the employer who
says I'm going to force the issue and
turn you into a one percent person
right because so many people you know
eight out of 10 people can't name a goal
that they have for themselves yeah the
other the other two out of ten or I said
let's say 20 out of 100 16 of those
never write their goals down four of
them do only one of them writes them
down and puts those up on the wall so
they can see them every day well that's
what I do I said if you're going to work
here if you're going to spend your time
here if you're going to earn money here
because it's hard
then you should reward yourself and
benefit from benefit from this so let's
put something out there that you can see
the progress of you gaining the picture
that is called your life it's like a
puzzle and you just start filling it in
and I got to tell you after they get
their first goal I don't care if it's
paying off a low balance Visa card
get out of the way because they go they
go crazy they become goal-oriented
machines after that and it's only
because they see themselves gaining on
their own life regardless of what you're
doing
that man is Ken Rusk he took what is now
considered an unconventional path might
be coming back into fashion that
conversation is on Fox Nation right now
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else